I don't want to have a label, I want to have a legacy.
Who would debut as a villain?
My first debut will be a villain, an antagonist.
But to me, that strikes me as exciting.
It's a very conscious effort for me to
do something that challenges me every year
You give anything, you tell me to paint the walls of the studio,
I'll do the best damn painting job you've ever seen
She's an actress, singer, film producer, philanthropist,
And the winner of the Miss World 2000 pageant.
One of India's highest-paid and one of the nation's most popular celebrities.
In 2016, TIME named her one of the 100 most influential people in the world.
She's Priyanka Chopra and here is my take on her top 10 Rules For Success.
Rule number 4 is my personal favorite,
And I'm curious if you're good which one you guys like the best.
Also as Priyanka is talking; if she says something that really really resonates with you,
Please leave it in the comments below and put quotes around it
So other people can inspired as well.
Enjoy
I don’t want to be called an actor.
I don’t want to be called a star.
I don’t want to have a label.
I want to have a legacy.
I want to be known as someone who has goals and achieves them,
And whatever they might be,
wherever they might be.
I want to be limitless.
I want to breake stereotypes
I want to go where no man or woman has gone before.
And it might be a scary path
And it might be a path that no one's taken,
But at least it'll be just mine.
I had the worst self-esteem when I was a kid
I was made fun of because of the way I talked,
Because of where I came from,
I was made fun of on every level
And the only way you can change that is setting goals for yourself, and saying
"I'll be the best version of me."
When I was 18 and I started doing movies
I gave myself a year and a half. And I said, if I don't;
If I sense that I'm not good at what I'm doing
And I don't see something opening up for me,
I'm going to go back to college.
I always had a plan B
I still always have a plan B.
And that's what I always tell young people, that
You know, life doesn't end, it just keeps moving.
You have to put your blinkers on
And find what you do best and just keep moving.
America suddenly sat up and said ‘Oh’, this is a great business module.
To take an international superstar and put them into something
and that just elevates the popularity.
Because today it’s not just about the domestic entertainment,
it’s global.
So now everyone wants that.
But the women, because we’re beautiful.
-That you are.
And the “exotic, beautiful, Indian girl”,
it’s an easier fit.
I’ve gone to the left and decided never to do it.
Because I did a show which is on my shoulders,
I’m doing a movie in which I’m not the side chick,
I’m the main villain of the movie,
which is different.
Who would debut as a
villain?
My first debut will be a villain,
an antagonist.
But to me, that strikes me as exciting.
I don’t like being conventional.
But I was tried to put into that box so much.
That was the first place I was put into.
All the movies that came to me was that.
In fact Baywatch, I was being spoken to for another
part.
And it was written for a man, that I told you last time
So, I like my terms a little bit
But the exotic, gorgeous, pretty girl in amazing clothes is so the fit of where people tried to put me.
And I hope that doesn’t happen to anyone else coming in
Because it’ll really ruin all the work I’ve done.
So you’re like on the phone; "Deepika, let me just lay down the rules here”.
No, no, no, everyone can do what they want.
We need to stand as a force to reckon with
because our industry is that.
Our industry is one of the most prolific in the world.
And we need to not be afraid to stand our ground on our feet and say, “I’m not settling”.
And I hope that Indian talent comes in and do that.
And I hope that me being in the position that I am in can give them the confidence to do it.
I've never known my life without movies,
I don't know what that would be like and now I'm doing music too in the last.
I mean I made an albume I've almost 40 songs ready
In the last tow years and I've finished 8 movies.
So I've been able to ...
-I'm sorry Superwomen where is your cape?
-I'm sorry what's going on?
You do you sleep?
I do, I do, but I do worked everyday
I love what I do, and I have tow careers that I have
to handle right now,
And I don't want to give up on
either on of them and I don't think I need to.
-Do you feel like if you don't work you go crazy?
I think so
-Like no I can't take because feel like .....
I've been working like the since I was 17
I don't know how to do anything else
And I haven't found a reason to want to take
a break yet,
If you know what I mean
"My name is Alex Parrish, protecting our country
had always my dream"
Quantico's my first audition,
I knew I had to go in to this room
and read these lines in front of all these people,
But I was so nervous before I went in,
So I went to the bathroom, I remember,
before I went in,
And looked in the mirror and it's so stupid and cliche,
I talked to myself, and I said, "What's wrong with you?"
"You've played the most difficult characters in
the most complicated movies"
I tossed my hair a little bit, felt great, and walked out.
Did my bit, and got the job.
Priyanka, do you as an actor have any lines
in your head
In terms of what you will do and won’t do?
Yea, nudity.
For sure, I wouldn’t do it.
Like never.
I play bold parts.
But
I don’t like a lot of skin show.
I don’t know how to explain it.
Like in "Aitraaz", I was always in pantsuits.
But the intensity and the part was sexual,
I didn't have to dress it.
You don’t have to dress provocatively.
Yea. I mean I would do it for a magazine cover here and there
Because it’s glamorous and its pretty.
Like one of the big reasons why I did the show
With ABC was because they're Disney
So there’s only that much for American standards
That we can do on the show
Which is pretty much as much as Hindi films.
There’s a difference between wearing a bikini and a bra
and I understand that.
And those lines are important to me.
It's a very conscious effort for me to do something that
challenges me every year.
I do one of those but,
I also do those where I can put my hair down
and just look pretty.
I'm a girl I love doing it.
I love blockbuster Hindi movies it's my favorite genre of film
Whether it's in Hollywood or in Bollywood.
You take me for an 'x-man';
I would much rather go see that than I would see a film which tells me a serious story,
I'm that audience.
Yeah sometimes I feel as an actor I don't get pushed and challenged as much
But you can't always be doing the same thing.
I like the Will Smith way of doing movies.
You do these big movies with big money and big budgets
And they are commercial
and they are successful
And look hot and you look great
and then you do that.
So you have to be able balance both.
Very few actors get to do it.
And I'm glad that I'm a part of that elite group of people.
I don't consider myself a singer
I don't consider myself an actor
I consider myself an achiever.
-Ok
You give me anything,
You'll tell me to paint the walls of the studio
And I'll do the best damn painting job
you've ever seen.
-Ok
That's how I've always been
I didn't know I was gonna be an actress
-Right
I didn't know I was gonna be a musician
But now, whatever opportunities I get
I trying turn them to "Let's see what will happened"
-Sure
Hard work is something i know i can damn well do
-Ok
So I do that ...... alright I'll try something else.
But I want to expand myself as an entertainer as a performer
Whether that's music, whether that's tv
Whether that's films, whether that's production, anything.
It is now, Priyanka, 8 o’ clock.
You just finished shooting
And now you’re heading to a party.
I’m heading to the launch of
of the magazine
Which is the W Magazine which is having a party for the launch of its Royals issue.
I’m on their covers,
so I’m heading their now, yes.
Kill me!
You don’t look like
you’re feeling a ‘Kill Me!’ moment.
How do you do that?
That’s never the debate Anu.
That’s why people don’t think I’m ever tired.
So how do you do this?
How do you will yourself
into not being tired?
It’s only because all the stuff that I have to do is what I need to do.
I don’t have time for unnecessary work between two continents.
My word is my bond.
It’s my commitment
I’m professional.
My inherent nature is that
You have to keep working if you’re committed to something.
So you’re tired,
but when you step out of this car
It’s going to be
the million dollar smile.
No one will know.
That's the thing.
My mum used to say this to me.
As a woman, no one should see the chinks in your armour
Because it is only your own.
We’re strong because
we have the ability as women
To be able to hold on to a lot of emotional, a lot of things that are thrown at us.
But we just have to remember that,
don’t let the world see your weakness.
The most beautiful thing about having dreams is
That it's in your hands how big your dreams become.
And this film taught me that.
I've come here only to intoduce you to the idea of saying that
No one can tell you that your dream is too small! or your dream can't come true
Or your dream can't be allowed because you're a girl because you're a boy
Because you look a certain way
or because you come from a certain place.
I'm not even know this turn and I'm playing Mary Kom
I mean who would thought that.
I'm extremely honored to be sitting in front of all of you
Wonderful wonderful really smart people and talking to you
About my dream which came true
doing this film.
Don't be afraid to dream guys because they do come true, they really do.
When I was very young,
I was 19 and I was doing
the first few movies,
I remember the producer just
said,
"Well, if she can't work it out, it's fine,
we'll just cast someone else."
"Girls are replaceable."
Subconsciously, it really worked on my mind
And I started picking up parts which were strong
Which were not just the damsel in distress waiting for someone to rescue me.
Now 13-15 years later, the movies I do
I'm irreplaceable.
Thank you guys so much for watching
I made this video because Gopi Acharya -I hope I pronounced okay- asked me to,
So if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you're made a profile next,
Leave it down in the comments below, and I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know what a Priyank say that really had a meaningful impact on you?
What was your favorite
rule and why?
What you had learn most from this video?
Please leave it in the comments below
and I'm gonna join in the discussion
Finally, I want to give a quick shout to Scott J Weaver Senior,
Scott thank you so much for picking up a copy of my book "Your One Word"
It really really really really really means a lot to me.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you I hope you continue to believe in yourself
And whatever your one word is much love.
See you soon.